that was a that was a very crazy party
but yeah i think nowadays um i have my
fault like other like fellow cadets i
went with like they send me dm's and
they still call me by my last name
they've nev they never
we never call each other by our first
names um and they're just like holy [ __ ]
like you're on youtube and meanwhile
like uh something too with live my
oh really build provider yeah have any
of your friends that's my taxes
have you guys ever like seen like it
like messages from like people that
you didn't even talk to like that
recognize what you do now yeah yeah all
the time
i actually i actually got one message of
this uh
this person who i hadn't talked to since
school and uh she
she's a teacher now so um last time i
met her was like years and years and
years ago and she messages me out
of the blue to be like yo um
i've talked to you in years but uh can
you do me a small
favor and she's that's never a good sign
and uh she asked me to record a message
for her for her students because
apparently her students were like big
fans of me
um and and i was just like
you know what [ __ ] it i'll do it you
know you can be
you can be the cool teacher for your
kids i'm gonna let you want it yeah i'm
gonna let you have this
and so i record the message and
apparently after that she was yeah she
was the cool [ __ ] teacher
so yeah it's it's so bizarre because
like ever since like you know during uni
when i was doing it like i
never told my uni friends or high school
friends that i was a youtuber
so like when i got all these messages on
facebook from like high school friends
that i haven't seen in like
[ __ ] 10 years almost them being like
yo i saw you on youtube the other day
i've been watching you for a while i'm
like what'd you say to that how did you
react to this i was like
thanks but also hey it's been 10 years
like what are you doing
you know it's like yeah like how do you
react to that would you would you guys
go to your high school union
union i don't know my high school was
tiny so like i
felt like i was pretty good friends with
most of them right yeah yeah my house i
think i had like
like 30 40 people in my year yeah it was
really really small
i had like 800 so
you had more people in your class than
we did our entire school
yeah we were my school was attached to
another school which was an
english-speaking school
and i think one of their years was
nearly the same size as our whole
school yeah our entire school i think
had like 600 kids
yeah something about that yeah something
around that and we were considered one
of the biggest schools too
oh wow it's really really big australia
really be all over the place
with that [ __ ] i don't know like because
do reunions happen every
10 years is it i think it is yeah it's
going to be 10 years who because who
arranges these you know so i
recently looked at like to see if my
school was doing one
right and usually it's where are you
looking what your school your school's
website and there is a specific section
for alumni there's a website
yeah yeah i'll call out a website oh
really my school has like a section like
that says alumni
yeah i've always wondered who like is it
like someone from the year or was like
one of the teachers
or schools i think it's my students
my high school union which i couldn't go
to because uh i was bidding on ax
but uh it was sorted out by one of the
people
in my class so it wasn't even the school
that sorted my one because it would be
because for me it'd be next year 2022
would be 10 years
i imagine that's when high school unions
were a thing it served a pretty good
purpose which was you could actually see
these people who hadn't seen it yeah
yeah yeah it's like well i've got
everyone on facebook and
i see their instagram photo like even if
you have it's true but
i feel like i feel like the the purpose
of it has really like
diminished yeah it's still good i think
i would still go because i'd like to see
what i want to talk to everyone but
i'd like to i actually really i've i've
really wanted to go
but i wasn't i'd like to go if there was
like you know the teachers there as well
that you were like
yeah you know like catch up with
teachers that you were really friendly
with surely it's got to be like
you know how depending on how you want
to go is depending on is your life
better than when you're in like
school right because some people it's up
or down it should be up
right right some people you know maybe
went down a little bit you know maybe
their golden era was school
right and then it's like yeah do i want
to go
that's true like yours was last year
right or this year i guess
what the high school yeah 10 years
because when what year did you graduate
2011 yeah so it'd be this year yeah it'd
be this year and that's why i was
checking because i was like oh it's
reaching 10 years and i they're like for
us
we have our school's website and there's
literally a section for alumni and it
says like homecoming and
you get to log in and say like are you
going and i saw a list of everyone who's
going
and it's so organized like it's because
our school's actually been around for a
while so they've had the
time i guess valley has a twitter i
think oh really
i don't know if my school is a twitter
oh god yeah and like
i'd be weird yeah i followed i followed
my school on twitter
i think i just wanted to check who is
going but in order to do that i had to
sign up to the website but i think it
put me on the list so then i got these
messages from like old high school
people like being
you're going and i'm like no i'm just
struggling
i'm just lucky no promises no problem
it's not going to show up because i
because i've heard like
there are some high schools where like
say like they don't have a website where
it's literally just
someone from that year being like so
i've like booked the board like down the
road
like what happened yeah exactly yeah it
was literally just a facebook group like
everyone got invited to
and apparently some people showed up and
i kind of wish i did i
i mean i remember when i was in high
school obviously you see them on tv all
the time high school reunions i'm like i
don't [ __ ] see anyone
here i don't want to meet anyone i'm
like that one edgy anime character who's
like right
they don't all know they all bullied me
i don't know that i'm 1200 raiding in
chess
but it's that [ __ ] meme where the guy
standing in the corner being like they
don't
yeah they don't know i'm a pro player
in the first three years i was like i
nah [ __ ] high school
i'm too cool for that but then more and
more it goes down i'm like you know what
i think i'd actually like to see
how everyone's going yeah i'm genuinely
i'm genuinely curious especially
during quarantine i had this like
weekend when i'm just like i wonder what
everyone's up to because
i feel like you get that day one like
one day you hire a pi what do you do
guys no just like just you know you see
what people are up to on facebook
because you haven't talked to them in
years
yeah they had all these dreams and
aspirations you you want do you see some
people who are
able to uh like you know some people who
have just been stuck
in their hometown i feel like most
people wanted that where
i grew up they the whole i think it was
almost expected that you
never really leave the town yeah i feel
like that's like a small town mindset
because i feel like a lot of people uh i
talked to sydney's family a lot and the
people in
living in her town and everyone kind of
just stays
in that one town and you're kind of like
you're kind of like part of a clan
and if you leave the clan you're like
just you're banished you're discovering
the clown you're right you're like the
one who thought you were too good